-Who is better?
Who is better than Miley Cyrus?
-You always decide how
the show kind of goes,
what we're going to do,
and how it's going to flow.
And I don't know if everyone
gets to sit
and tell you how much
they appreciate you
and sitting on your couch.
You are one of my favorite
people to talk to.
And when I come to New York,
I look forward to coming
and sitting and talking to you.
You make everyone feel so good,
so comfortable.
The Roots always sound amazing.
This is the most fun show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you for saying that.
-You tell everyone,
"You're the best.
Miley Cyrus, everybody."
He's always announcing everyone.
You are just so fun
to come and see.
I just feel so happy to be here.
-I legitimately think
you are the best.
-I think you are.
-We've had Miley Week here --
-I can't believe
you let me do that.
I came out, and I saw
your audience before the show.
And I don't even know --
I don't think I was --
Why was I here for a whole week?
-I don't know.
There was no reason.
-I don't even know
if I had
an album or anything.
I think I just said, "Jimmy,
can I be on your show
for a full week?"
And you said, "Yeah,
uh, do you want to open
for Hillary Clinton?"
-Oh, yeah.
-She was here.
-Hillary was here.
We did sketches.
-"Boots Are Made for Walking."
I got to perform with Sandler.
It was such a --
I don't know why I was here.
-I have no idea
why you were here.
-I got to play with,
you know, The Roots.
-But you were very nice.
You were nice to everybody.
And everyone on your team was
nice to everyone on our crew.
It just gelled.
It was awesome.
By the end of the week,
we were all almost in tears
that you were leaving
because we were like,
"She's so fun,"
and we were going to miss you.
As you were leaving,
you were like, "By the way,
I just donated
all this money to your charity."
And I go, "Thank you
for doing that."
-Great people that do
great things
are my favorite kind of people.
-But you did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was the extra move.
You're like...
Just sunk a three-pointer
on the way out.
I loved it.
-I love it.
-Let's talk about
New Year's Eve.
-Yeah.
-Okay, this is giant.
You're back in Miami?
-Yes, I'm back in Miami.
-Ooh, I love it.
Last year was unbelievable.
-I refuse to be cold,
and I've learned my lesson
in this building
that it is always freezing.
So, I was cold,
so I'm wearing gloves.
-We like to keep it cold here.
-They are extremely fashionable
and sickening,
but they're also
for functionality.
I am freezing.
-Yeah.
-So, I -- you know,
Dolly Parton
is my co-host this year.
-Now, come on,
That's -- Dolly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
I called Dolly,
and I asked her,
"Would you do New Year's?"
And she goes, "Miley, I want to,
but I just can't be cold.
I can't go to New York
for New Year's."
I said, "It's not in New York.
It's in Miami.
It's going to be warm.
We can wear little clothes."
And she said, "I'm in."
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, come on.
-She is the best.
-Here's you and Dolly.
This is the shot.
-Me and my fairy Godmother.
-That's it. That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's one of the most charming,
funniest --
She's one of the --
She's a pro.
-She really is.
-She just knows.
She's like, "Yeah,
what are we going to do?
Hit that mark and do this."
And then she'll surprise me
with a joke.
-And talking
about the kindness.
It is like, unparalleled
how gracious she is
in every single room
that she is in.
-Yes.
-I remember
when she was on
"Hannah Montana"
and she played my aunt,
she came in
and brought doughnuts
and Dolly merch for everyone.
[ Light laughter ]
-Here's you and Dolly
from "Hannah Montana."
-Yep.
-And she was on our show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was saying how cool
she was for doing that,
and she turned it around
and said
how cool you were
to have her on.
-I know.
She always says that.
-"Because you introduced me
to a whole new audience."
-I don't know if Dolly knows
what Dolly is. You know?
-She's unbelievable.
-She really is.
-We got to be in
the same movie together.
-That's right.
And Dolly loves Christmas.
She loves the holidays.
She's like a little kid
at Christmastime.
-She's perfect
for the holidays.
-When I watched
the "Mountain Magic,"
and she saw snow
for the first time
in that opening scene,
I started crying.
-She can act.
-It's the most pure reaction.
She's not acting.
She loves snow.
-She's so childlike and fun
and a pro,
and I danced with her.
I had a scene where I got
to dance with Dolly Parton.
And I'm not kidding, I danced
with her from 10:00 to 3:00 --
not 9:00 to 5:00.
-Ohh.
-But 10:00 to 3:00, I was like,
"Ah, we're so close."
-So close.
-I know. We didn't do it.
-You didn't commit to that joke.
-Have you celebrated
the holidays with Dolly before?
-We haven't really done
Christmas together.
We always talk around
the holidays, you know?
I called her the other day
to talk about the show
and what we were going to do.
And I said,
"What are you doing, Dolly?"
She said, "Well, I'm sitting
at home,
and I'm signing
all my Christmas cards."
I go, "Okay,
I'm doing it tomorrow."
And she goes, "Well,
I'm doing it right now."
She's very competitive.
-She's like, "Yeah,
I'm doing it right now."
-"I'll do it tomorrow."
"Well, I'm doing it now."
-Can you say what you have
planned, or who's performing?
I know you're going to sing.
-So, Dolly told me
she wanted to do
something different
that she had never done before.
And what I think
I love about that
is a lot of people
feel that way around New Year's.
That resonates.
I think everybody knows when
the clock turns midnight,
they think that we're all
going to magically change.
But nothing changes
unless you change,
unless you are making
those choices to be different.
And so, Dolly being different,
I'm convinced it's going to be
the same silhouette we've had
since, you know --
I don't know how different
it's going to get.
If Dolly shows up an "A" cup,
which I don't think
is happening...
and a little brunette haircut --
I don't think it's happening.
So, I sent her a pair of some
leopard gloves that I had.
And I said,
"I think we can work off that."
And she sent me back
some leopard hair.
She's always got to one-up.
-And who is performing?
Can we say?
-So, right now, Sia is coming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's one of my favorite --
-I love Sia.
-She's one of my favorite
artists.
And I love as many wigs
as we can have as possible.
So, we have Sia.
-Yeah.
-We have Latto.
Rae Sremmurd,
who are friends of mine.
-Oh, my gosh.
-As we get closer to the show,
I want to start revealing
who else we have.
But the lineup is very me.
It is curated in a way
that makes no sense,
but makes total sense.
-I don't know how you pulled it
off, though, when you did it,
because it was COVID.
It was just getting
out of COVID.
It was just tricky.
Everyone was like,
"I don't know
if you're going to
pull this off."
-Lorne Michaels makes magic.
-Lorne is great.
-We get there,
and COVID was happening.
And we wanted to do the most
responsible thing
that we could do.
We really -- We had barely
any audience.
I just had a couple friends
and my own family members there.
We had kind of thought
of everything,
except that
the Telemundo Studios
is right by the airport.
We didn't think about that part.
And planes kept going by.
And that was really what was
starting to ruin the show.
And somehow,
Lorne Michaels called
and got all air traffic
to stop before the air...
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-...so no planes could fly
overhead while we did our show.
-I never heard this story.
-Everyone now when they realize
that their holiday plans
were ruined
because they had
to fly over Miami
and they had major delays
hate me.
[ Laughter ]
-You or Lorne.
-It's not me. It's Lorne.
-It's Lorne.
Yeah, it's Lorne.
I'm looking forward to it.
It's a must watch.
And I'm so happy
you're doing New Year's again.
It's going to be fantastic.
-If you feel like being
in Miami for New Year's,
you're more than welcome --
you all always are.
-I can always bring the...
Roots, ready to get on a bus
and see what we can do?
-Well, I take this seriously,
so, you know, we'll talk
about it after the show.
But you're welcome
for any New Years.
For anything I ever do,
you're always welcome.
You all are.
I just love it so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Miley, I have a big question.
-Oh, what's up?
-I have a big question for you.
And I don't know if you heard,
but I'm making
a decision tonight,
a big change.
Like you said, we're always
looking for change.
-The theme.
-It's the theme.
New Year's Eve, we're looking
for something different,
and the only change happens
unless you do it.
-Right.
-But I would like you
to do it for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-I want to shave --
I want to shave my beard.
-Oh, you're sure?
You want to shave your beard?
What do y'all think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you want me
to shave your beard?
-Would you do it?
-Absolutely.
-You will do it?
-Anything you need from me.
-Let's do this.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Miley Cyrus is shaving my beard
when we come back, everybody.
Come on back.